The endgame of the Fast & Furious franchise
is coming. Can Dom and his
family survive? Let's ride.
Almost as soon as "F9: The Fast
Saga" unspooled in theaters in 2021,
fans wanted to know "What's next?" And more
importantly, they wanted to know when the
follow-up and tenth installment in the "Fast
and Furious" franchise would arrive in theaters.
Entertainment Weekly reported in August 2021
that the still tentatively titled "Fast & Furious
10" would start filming in January 2022 in
advance of a release date of April 7, 2023.
A few months later, Universal changed course
and pushed back the release of the film, now
officially known as "Fast X". The film's release
date was officially changed to May 19, 2023.
According to the plot summary on the film's
official website, "Fast X" is the beginning of
the endgame for the franchise. Dominic Toretto and
his family stare down what's perhaps their most
dangerous endeavor yet. Back in "Fast Five," Dom
and company took down drug kingpin Hernan Reyes.
Twelve years have passed, and his revenge-minded
son who witnessed his father's end has spent the
entire period devising an elaborate and probably
fatal revenge plot. Surviving and fighting back
will take the huge and ever-expanding crew around
the world, from Rome to Los Angeles to Portugal,
and even Antarctica. As this movie is supposed to
start to wrap up the series, plenty of long unseen
characters — heroic and villainous — are likely
to return to take sides in the developing war.
And it seems that not every character
will make it out of "Fast X" alive.
"One of us might not come back
from this. But we have to fight."
Director Louis Leterrier told Empire,
"There's a war brewing. It's coming to an end,
and it is a race to the finish. There
will be some tremendous casualties."
He also added that the movie promises to
be so exciting that it's suggested in the
title. He pronounces "Fast X" as "fast
ten" — like "fasten your seatbelts."
"Family" is extremely and repeatedly important
to the "Fast and Furious" franchise, so expect
plenty of familiar faces to return to the series
when it arrives in theaters in May 2023. Among the
returning cast members are Vin Diesel as Dominic
Toretto, Jordana Brewster as Mia Toretto, Tyrese
Gibson as Roman, Michelle Rodriguez as Letty
Ortiz, Sung Kang as Han, Charlize Theon as Cipher,
Helen Mirren as Queenie, John Cena as Jakob,
Nathalie Emmanuel as Ramsey, Chris "Ludacris"
Bridges as Tej, Michael Rooker as Buddy, and
Jason Statham as villain-turned-hero Deckard Shaw.
New additions to that already ridiculously
packed cast include "Reacher" star Alan Ritchson,
Oscar winners Brie Larson and Rita Moreno,
Portuguese film star Daniela Melchior,
and beloved action hero and "Aquaman"
himself, Jason Momoa, as Dante Reyes.
The tenth official entry in the "Fast and
Furious" saga will bear the creative thumbprint
of a director new to the franchise. Justin Lin,
who helmed 2009's "Fast and Furious," 2011's
"Fast Five," 2013's "Fast & Furious 6," and 2021's
"F9: The Fast Saga," left the directorial duties
this time to Louis Letterier. Experienced
in the eye-popping action movie milieu,
Leterrier directed "Fast X" costar Jason
Statham in "The Transporter" and its sequel,
as well as the 2008 MCU entry "The Incredible
Hulk," the 2010 remake of "Clash of the Titans,
and all 10 episodes of Netflix's "The
Dark Crystal: Age of Resistance."
Lin didn't entirely leave the "Fast and Furious"
family, however. He collaborated on the "Fast X"
screenplay with Daniel Casey, a re-pairing
of the team who wrote the script for "F9:
The Fast Saga." That film's story came
from the mind of writer Alfredo Botello,
and he similarly contributed
the plot outline for "Fast X."
After 10 mainline films, the franchise is
coming to a close. But as the trailers for
"Fast X" suggest, the latest outing is only
the beginning of the end. "Fast X" may mark
the end of "Fast & Furious" as we know it, but
it's only the first part of the story. After
previous reports that "Fast X" would conclude
the series, Variety announced that "The Fast
Saga" would end with a two-part finale, one that
will reclaim the franchise's street racing roots.
Though we don't yet know the title or the release
date for the final installment — which will mark
Vin Diesel's 10th portrayal of Dom Toretto after
skipping out on "2 Fast 2 Furious" — we do know
that the "Fast & Furious" team is working hard
to develop a rewarding conclusion. When speaking
with "Variety," Diesel further explained
the decision to end the franchise with
the eleventh feature by comparing the series
to J.R.R. Tolkien's "The Lord of the Rings."
"There's a reason Tolkien stopped writing
after a while. Because it's so
hard to continue mythologies."
The longer this franchise — which went to
outer space in "F9" — goes on, the harder
it is to keep it grounded and interesting.
Here's hoping "F11" finishes in first.
Like many of the more recent "Fast & Furious"
pictures, the cast and crew of "Fast X" find
themselves traveling all over the world. While
the Torretto clan is based in Los Angeles, they
seem to find themselves breaking international
laws consistently. "Fast X" is no different.
This time, the street-racing spy thieves find
themselves filming in the United Kingdom,
Italy, and Portugal. Specifically, the
"Fast X" team made their way to Rome,
where actor Jason Momoa was seen
filming scenes for the movie.
Aside from their international escapades, the
"Fast X" team returned to Angelino Heights to
film the majority of the LA scenes,
with plenty of car chases and intense
stunts making waves across their usual
stomping grounds. As "Variety" reported,
locals weren't too enthusiastic about the film's
return, with some even organizing protests against
the production. Ever since the first film was
released in 2001, popular "Fast & Furious"
filming locations — namely Bob's Market from
the first film — have been desired points of
interest for fans and reckless drivers alike,
leading to dangerous incidents on local roads.
Of course, not everyone was upset about the
movie being filmed in their neighborhood.
Homeowner Planaria Price made it clear that she
didn't want filming to end, telling Variety,
"It's one of the most important
economic things we have in Los Angeles."
Known for its clever retcons and devil-may-care
attitude, "The Fast Saga" isn't the easiest
franchise to sit down and watch without the proper
context. Some of the earliest films actually
take place later on in the timeline, while later
movies serve as prequels of sorts. Still, the very
first film, "The Fast and the Furious," is where
everyone should start, as it introduces the world
and the primary characters, namely Vin Diesel's
Dom Toretto and Paul Walker's Brian O'Conner.
After the original 2001 feature, Brian's
adventures continue in the sequel "2 Fast
2 Furious," although Dom doesn't reunite with
his friend until 2009's "Fast & Furious," which
is technically the fourth film but serves
as the third chronologically. From there,
"Fast Five" and "Fast & Furious 6" continue the
plot threads established in the fourth film. The
third film released in the series, "The Fast and
the Furious: Tokyo Drift," takes place immediately
after the sixth film leading into "Furious 7,"
which ties every previous installment together.
While "Furious 7" was notable as Walker's last
portrayal of Brian O'Conner before his untimely
death, the series continued with "The Fate of
the Furious." Tying in with the main franchise,
"Fast & Furious Presents: Hobbs &
Shaw" takes place after "The Fate
of the Furious" but before "F9." "Fast X"
will directly follow the events of "F9" and
begin the end of the Toretto clan's
international adventures together.
From the very first "Fast & Furious" adventure,
Paul Walker's Brian O'Conner made his mark on the
franchise and quickly solidified himself
as a member of the Toretto family. After
becoming best friends with Dom and
having children with his sister Mia,
the Brian character was retired following
"Furious 7" due to Paul Walker's real-life death.
Both "The Fate of the Furious" and "F9" offered
explanations for his lack of involvement. Still,
the character remains a part of the
overarching "Fast & Furious" story.
"Brian and Mia got out of the
game when they became parents."
"We're not them."
It seems like "The Fast Saga" can only hold
out on showing Brian again for so long,
and it's becoming increasingly unlikely
that the character would continue to
sit out each and every new conflict that
Dom, Letty, and the gang find themselves
involved in. "Furious 7" sent off Brian
well in a respectful ending that honored
Walker and the character. But with all
the constant teases and references,
it's becoming increasingly less believable that
Brian wouldn't show up again at some point.
When speaking with "Total Film," Vin
Diesel made it clear that "The Fast
Saga" won't end without a proper sendoff
for Paul Walker's breakout character.
"I will give you this without spoiling
anything. I couldn't imagine this saga
ending without truly saying
goodbye to Brian O'Conner."
In almost every "Fast & Furious" movie,
we're introduced to a new villain who has
some strange hold over our favorite found
family. This has ranged from international
terrorists to drug lords and assassins,
with some of Dom's most hated enemies becoming
uneasy allies later on. With "Fast X," Jason
Momoa has been added to the ever-growing list
of adversaries, but like "Furious 7" nemesis
Deckard Shaw before him, Momoa's Dante Reyes also
has a previous connection to Dom and his crew.
As revealed in the "Fast X" trailers, Dante's
time in "The Fast Saga" extends back to "Fast
Five," when Dom, Brian, and their crew took
down drug lord Hernan Reyes. While Momoa
obviously didn't show up in "Fast Five,"
clever retconning and repurposed footage
have included him in the narrative. Though it
was technically Luke Hobbs who executed Reyes,
the makeshift Toretto family was ultimately
responsible for the drug lord's defeat.
Hoping to enact his revenge
against his father's killers,
Momoa's character is rooted within the
franchise's mythology and aims to be
the perfect antithesis of Dom. As director
Louis Leterrier described him to Esquire,
"He's also the polar opposite of Dom. He's all
color and flamboyance. It's the [yin] and yang,
the Christ and the Anti-Christ — the anti-Dom."
One of the strangest additions to the later
years of "The Fast Saga" was the government
spymaster Mr. Nobody. Played to perfection by Kurt
Russell, Mr. Nobody first appeared in "Furious 7,"
at the tail end of Brian O'Conner's tenure in the
series. With the advent of this secret super-spy,
Dom and his family were ushered into
a new world of international espionage
with potentially disastrous consequences.
Appearing in the last three installments,
Russell's character isn't slated to appear
in "Fast X," leaving his fate ambiguous.
At the beginning of "F9: The Fast
Saga," Mr. Nobody is credited with
capturing Cipher and transporting her
by plane back to the US. Unsurprisingly,
this transport doesn't go as planned
and Mr. Nobody's plane goes down,
leaving Cipher to join Jakob Toretto on his
revenge mission against Dom. In all the chaos,
the fate of Mr. Nobody is never officially
addressed. Though Han eventually explains
how the agent helped him fake his death,
his current whereabouts remain unclear.
Although Russell is not returning
for "Fast X" — at least as far as
we know — Mr. Nobody's daughter Tess is
set to appear. Played by Brie Larson,
the trailers suggest that Tess will aid Dom and
his team in their mission against Dante Reyes,
acting in a similar capacity as her
father did when working with the team.
Ever since "Fast Five," Dwayne Johnson has been
an iconic part of the "Fast & Furious" franchise,
though his involvement has not been without some
controversy. Series star Vin Diesel had initially
fought for Johnson's casting as government
bounty hunter Luke Hobbs in the fifth film,
but the two clashed on set. Johnson
reprised his role in "Fast & Furious
6" and "Furious 7," but took a break during
the eighth installment, instead developing
his own spin-off with Jason Statham in
"Fast & Furious Presents: Hobbs & Shaw."
"When it comes to the fate of the
world, it becomes my business."
Johnson also skipped "F9: The Fast Saga," though
his spin-off co-star reprised his role as Shaw for
an uncredited after-credits sequence. While
Statham is set to return as Shaw once more
for "Fast X," Hobbs will not be joining him.
Since Johnson's character was so important to
"Fast Five" — he executed Hernan Reyes, after
all — it will be interesting to see how "Fast
X" deals with Hobbs' absence and if Dante Reyes
will even attempt to assassinate Hobbs as well.
While Dwayne Johnson has repeatedly distanced
himself from "The Fast Saga," fans still hope
to see Luke Hobbs once more before the
franchise closes out. With no concrete
news on a potential "Hobbs & Shaw" sequel
and Johnson's disinterest in returning
to the main series, it's probably a
safe bet to assume that Hobbs' story
will come to a close off-screen. It's
not ideal, but that's show business.
"Fast & Furious" fans are also eager to see
Gal Gadot's Gisele return. First appearing
in the fourth installment, "Fast & Furious,"
Gisele joined Dom's crew as a weapons expert
and specialist. As a former CIA agent,
she was an enormous asset to the team
in both "Fast Five" and "Fast & Furious
6." Sadly, Gisele met her end saving her
boyfriend Han near the tail end of the sixth
movie, and many fans still aren't over it.
"Gisele."
Aside from some passing mentions and a
deleted scene from "Furious 7," Gadot
has been too busy playing Wonder Woman
in the DCEU to return full-time to the
franchise. After Han's death in "Tokyo Drift"
and subsequent return in "F9" — which followed
Letty's "death" and resurrection a few
films prior — it's as possible as ever that
Gisele's demise could've been faked also,
especially given her ties to Mr. Nobody.
While there hasn't been any official
confirmation regarding Gisele's return
to "The Fast Saga," "The Direct" reported
that Gal Gadot had filmed scenes for "Fast
X." In response to questions regarding Gisele's
possible resurrection, Han actor Sung Kang told
"Digital Spy" that there was no reason the two
couldn't be reunited by the franchise's end.
"Why can't she? ... Who doesn't want
a load of Gal Gadot in their life?"
If she does return, odds are good that her
survival will be revealed
in a post-credits sequence.
On March 10, with just over two months
until the film was set to hit theaters,
Vin Diesel filmed a short scene characterized
as a "tag" or "button," or what fans might just
call a "post-credits scene." He may have
filmed it with a co-star whose identity
wasn't confirmed or revealed. Could Gal
Gadot be his alleged secret scene partner?
It seems that with almost every new venture
into "The Fast Saga," the movies get bigger
and increasingly more expensive. Following the
success of the fifth and sixth films, "Furious
7" was given a larger budget that, after the death
of Paul Walker, quickly grew to $250 million for
digital recreations and reshoots. The following
film, "The Fate of the Furious," was granted a
similar budget, while the next two franchise
installments, "Hobbs & Shaw" and "F9," cost
$200 million each. These budgets were a far cry
from the original film's budget of $38 million.
As the first part of a greater franchise finale,
"The Wrap" reported that the new film's budget
is pushing $340 million, making it one of the
most expensive films ever made. In comparison,
"Avengers: Endgame" had a budget of $356 million
and the budget for James Cameron's "Avatar:
The Way of Water" was reported to
be somewhere around $350 million.
Though "Fast X" is less expensive than those two,
it's still more costly than popular blockbusters
including "Avengers: Infinity War" or "Pirates
of the Caribbean: At World's End." Exact numbers
aside, the point is that "Fast X" will be huge,
and while a big budget does not necessarily equal
a hit, we can hope that the extra cash will
be used wisely to bring the story to life.
If one thing is obvious about "The Fast
and the Furious" and its many sequels,
it's that every new addition gets
just a bit bigger and even harder
to believe. A film that was originally
about illegal racing, stolen DVD players,
and one cop's infiltration of a street gang
quickly shifted genres and became something
bigger than anyone had previously thought
possible. In the sequel, Brian goes undercover
to take down a drug kingpin. In "The Fast and
the Furious: Tokyo Drift," everything changes,
focusing instead on American Sean Boswell
in Tokyo as he falls into street racing.
From the fourth film on, the franchise
found its voice as an adrenaline-fueled,
car-centric heist series, but it evolved
into something even bigger from there, too.
"I don't have friends. I got family."
The franchise since has turned into a
globe-trotting action series with ties to the
spy genre, with each film becoming increasingly
unrealistic as the series pressed onward. However,
that's not what "Fast X" director Louis
Leterrier hopes to do with the 10th
installment. The director told "Esquire"
when discussing his vision for the film,
"What I wanted to do on this one, because it's
very much my style, was to ground it more in
reality. I wanted it to feel like 'Fast 1,' 'Fast
3,' and 'Fast 5' — movies that feel grounded."
Whether that actually translates to the big
screen remains to be seen, but audiences will
get a chance to see for themselves when "Fast
X" comes roaring into theaters on May 19.